[Music]
good morning thank you for coming to
everyone on the livestream thank you for
watching thank you for your interest in
accessibility my name is Phil Weaver
I'm here with cousin Sadiq and Isha Bo
bruh and we want to talk to you this
morning about demystifying Android
accessibility development and what we
mean by demystifying is there's a
tremendous amount of complexity in
accessibility and sort of as part of
Android we're trying we I think our job
is partly to try to avoid having
developers deal with that complexity and
as we've looked at some of our API is we
feel like we've maybe not done as good a
job on that as we should have so we want
to do is present some ideas here the
overall idea of how we think about
accessibility and also some new api's
we've done for for to try to simplify
your experience and some tools we have
to talk about to help you test your
products so I'm gonna do a bit of a
run-through of our high-level opinion
castas gonna talk a bit about api's each
is going to talk about testing and I'll
talk a bit at the end wrap up so let's
start with three simple things about
accessibility I feel like as I think
about this I personally no more than
three things about accessibility I'm
working on this for close to a decade so
I maybe know like five things but if
what I think a lot of other areas where
I work where like internationalization
version control sort of a whole range of
things where I kind of know a few things
and that's kind of enough to get through
like my overall workflow as I feel like
there should be probably three things
that everybody in the world should know
about accessibility it's sort of built
into their daily work I think the first
one is very simply to make information
visible and a lot of people think about
accessibility they start think about
screen readers and people who cannot see
and there's a lot of people in that
category and that's important there's
also a lot of people who just have low
vision or like me are getting older and
it's harder to read small fonts and so
just making sure that your information
is as visible as possible without
anybody having to turn on any tools or
do anything fancy with accessibility
one of the most common things we see
people struggle with there's a lot of
designers who will kind of design
something that's you know looks really
great because it's light gray on
slightly lighter gray and I think a lot
of us have seen that in both in designs
we're trying to implement and designs
that we were struggling to use or fonts
that are just too small because too much
information is being crammed in the into
a page the other thing to think about is
color if you're using color to convey
information keep in mind that there's a
lot of people out there who are
colorblind and so they're just missing
the information you're trying to convey
but so just in general if you can think
about how to make information visible
you can get a long ways to just reaching
more and more people the second would
sort of the complement of that which is
assuming somebody can see your UI and
understand what you're trying to convey
are they able to actually use it and
that's where just simple big controls
can make a big difference I think again
we've all had the experience of somebody
who got a little carried away of just
trying to add too much configurability
into too small a space and you it ends
up being kind of random which button you
end up hitting and for somebody with a
little bit less motor control or
somebody with just really big fingers
there's a whole range of things that
they're experience of using UIs that
maybe we don't find to be too tight
their experience can be the same as what
we've was ours when we're sort of
struggling with something that's just
clearly way too close together just
making sure that in both cases
information big and bold controls big
and simple to understand and the third
one really gets into sort of a lot of
what often is thought of first for
accessibility which is to help users who
can't see the screen if you're using an
image to convey information after you've
made it as visible as possible also make
sure it works for people who can't see
it at all and the simplest way to do
that is just to label the image and we
have a very simple API that Casa del
mentioned that can help you do that when
you go to label things you want to label
it precisely because you're trying to
convey information make sure that
information is conveyed in the text but
on the other hand if you think about the
experience of a screen reader user
they're particularly if it's like a
control or something they're going to go
to all the time they don't want to hear
a long treatise
about how exciting this particular
graphic is they really want to just get
on with their with their day and get on
with whatever action that thing can do
so you want to label things concisely
these two things are a little bit in
tension with one another so part of this
is like are you for trying to really
just convey information and that's
what's in there make sure that's
conveyed as precisely as possible if
you're trying to just explain to
somebody how to use something just one
word which is a verb is usually enough
so that's three things but you may have
come here to learn more than three
things so we want to dig a little bit
deeper and just think about how users
interact with your app much like the
three things there's essentially two
things that you're doing you're
presenting information to users and
you're allowing them to take actions on
your UI so often we designed for often
the first design ends up being for
people who sort of definitely not
necessarily have an accessibility need
but ideally you're thinking about this
up front but it quickly becomes kind of
overwhelming you start thinking about
okay how somebody who can't see going to
use my app how somebody whose motor
impaired going to use my app how
somebody who's deaf or hard-of-hearing
going to use my app so now you suddenly
you've got maybe four types of users
which is your original mainstream user
and then these three categories but
within these three categories the more
you stare at them the more complexity
you see it's like a fractal people who
are visually impaired there's all sorts
of different visual impairments we
wouldn't see different levels of detail
different types of things motor
impairments come in radical um sort of
variety of people out there and then
also there are people that have
combinations of these disabilities and
so what are you supposed to do as an app
developer I mean we there's it's like a
billion people in the world with a
disability are you supposed to think
through a billion use cases it is
there's no fortunately and nobody is
ever going to think through all billion
use cases but with an ecosystem like
this we do have the ability to scale to
that many use cases and the tool we use
to do that are accessibility services so
these are plugins to the Android
platform
that get information about the you I can
take actions on the UI on behalf of the
user
and they those developers can think
about how do I serve this particular set
of users that I'm targeting and so
they're the ones that are presenting the
information if somebody can't see the
screen they're presenting it audio or
Braille if somebody can't take actions
on the screen directly they may be using
a switch to do it and then these
services can inter mediate that the way
that they work is they work there they
get their information from the android
framework and they use the android
framework to take actions on the UI and
so down here at the bottom is your app
in your app just what it needs to do is
present the information to the android
framework so that the framework can then
share it with all these different
services to support these different
users and then it needs to allow the
framework to take actions on it so that
all these different services all these
different users can can actually get
control of your app so the way that you
can do this is village to use the api's
that casa is going to talk about in a
moment to make sure you're presenting
the information and allowing users take
actions on it and once you've done that
you can use these testing tools to
verify that your app is actually working
for a wide range of different users so
now let me hand it over to Acosta to
talk about these api's but everyone I'm
Gossett I'm on the Android accessibility
team let's talk about api's so Phil
mentioned the way your application
communicates what's visible on screen to
the accessibility service is the
accessibility API but thankfully for you
guys most of the information that an
accessibility service needs can already
be inferred through the view hierarchy
but there are some situations where you
guys actually do have to use their API
so thankfully those are minimal but let
me show you what I mean
so let you say you've made this
application and let's just say you've
got this more options button now our
frameworks can infer important
information like its position on screen
and
it's clickable the information in view
Java but when a talkback user a user who
may not be able to see the screen places
their finger on this item to hear a
description of this item they're not
going to get anything and the reason is
talk like really doesn't know what to
say in this situation there's no
descriptive text associated with it so
you as an app developer have to step in
and fill in the blanks for us and you
can do that through the content
description API all you do is pass in a
localized string into sight Content
description remember keep the string
localized concise and descriptive
because someone has to hear a user has
to hear it when Phil says label your
items he means this and for good reason
because this is mostly the accessibility
issues your application is going to have
and thankfully it's true really simple
to fix now our user knows that this is a
more options button and we have a
successful interaction so let's talk
about something different let's just say
you've got this email UI and like most
inbox UI is with a list of emails you
can tap an email to select it and you
can swipe to reveal that an email is
deletable and if you continue swiping
you'll do eat that email so this is
great and all but not all users can tap
and swipe on-screen a talkback uses for
example Drive the UI they were a
completely different gesture set switch
access users on the other hand they
drive the UI through a series of single
switches so for these particular
situations is the accessibility service
which access our talkback need to know
what actions you can perform on each
item or each of you in your hierarchy
now when switch axes go or they switch
access user highlights a certain item as
it currently stands the user only knows
that you can tap an item and this may be
because of the way we implemented that
remove action or that do we action so
again like content description we have
to fill in the blanks and you can do
that through our new accessibility
actions API all you do is call view
compat da add accessibility action you
pass in the view with the action
localized string describing the action
concisely to the user and a lambda to be
performed at the user's request
now our hypothetical switch user will be
able to perform both select and the
Dooley action and also because this is
an android x2 library we use to back
part a lot of our api this is going to
work back to api 21 okay so let's get
into a little bit something a little
more complicated let's talk about text
and links or clickable spans now before
android oh our accessibility frameworks
really couldn't handle non URL spans
well and this is a problem because you
can imagine users like talkback users
they wouldn't be informed that there are
links on screen they actually they
wouldn't be even able to activate them
so to solve this problem we added some
api int and so they wouldn't be they
would essentially see nothing so to
solve this problem we added some api
into Android X all you do for a textview
which contains these non URL clickable
spans is called view compatible
accessible clickable span support
passing the textview or the view that
contains these spans now our users all
the way back to api 19 will know that
these links exist and will be able to
successfully activate them okay so as
app developers a lot of you like to roll
some interesting custom UI so this may
look like an alert dialog but for
whatever reason we decided to implement
this using a view group a couple text
views and a button now this poses a
problem for accessibility services like
talkback because there's some
information that's visually expressed
about a context change happening on
screen but that actually hasn't happened
this behaves a bit like a window so our
accessibility user isn't informed about
this so the way you solve this is by
treating this view group as an
accessibility pane and you can do that
by calling view compat set accessibility
pane title on the view that you consider
a pane and you pass in a localized
concise string describing this pain to
the user now when our custom alert
appears talkback is going to speak alert
this also works all the way back to API
19 and finally let's say you have a
video player in your application and
it's pretty typical in that it has a
play button or some controls at timeout
and disappear after a certain period of
time that's useful because most users
just want to get to your content they
don't want to fiddle with your controls
but you can imagine an accessibility
user who needs to take time interacting
with your controls by the time they're
able to precisely interact with this
play button disappears now they've got
to figure out a way to get that play
button back up on screen they've got to
figure out a way to interact with it
before the timeout disappears again and
this is a pretty frustrating cycle so
what we ideally need in the situation is
a way to adjust our timeout based on our
current users needs and you can do that
through our new timeouts API first you
get a reference to the accessibility
manager then you call get recommended
timeout milliseconds this returns the
suggested timeout for your view it's
customized for your view and for your
user it does this by taking the default
timeout that you had planned and
adjusting it based on the type of
content this view is you specify this in
the second parameter in this situation
this is a play button and it's to
control so we pass in fly content
controls you can imagine a motor someone
with a motor disability for example may
need this adjusted if it's a control it
also presents visual information so we
pass in flight content icons for people
who may have trouble parsing visual
information if it was text we pass in
fly content text for people who have
trouble parsing text now we've got a
timeout that's customized for our view
and for the current user and a play
button that works for everybody okay so
those are the fundamentals and let's
just say you've used those fundamentals
to become an expert in our to make your
application accessible you've become a
bit of an expert but you're going to
really quickly discover there are some
murky areas places where it's not clear
what the right thing to do is let's get
back to this email UI now let's just say
you're trying to build very specifically
for the talkback using the users I can't
see on screen you trying to determine
what the experience is gonna be when a
new email appears and you try to figure
out how to express this change and you
figure the best thing you can do is by
making an announcement
every time a new email appears a Nancy
email well this is a bad idea and if you
catch yourself using the accessibility
event type announcement
you're probably conforming to this anti
pattern you see changes in the UI or
expressed very differently depending on
the accessibility service and the users
preferences services don't need
fine-tuning of accessibility UI from the
application they need a generic
representation of the UI that they
themselves can manipulate for the users
that they understand so well so what do
you do in this situation this is what
you do that's right you don't do
anything and you can do this by using
the widgets we provide to you in our
frameworks such as Android X and
material these widgets come with
accessibility built in out-of-the-box
which significantly reduce the amount of
work you as an app developer have to do
so you can really focus on the very
particular value that your application
provides to the world but if you really
must write your own custom widgets if
you really must do it yourself make sure
you're communicating the exact semantics
of the changes in your UI by using the
correct accessibility events and
populating it correctly remember in this
situation you're not communicating
directly with the user you're
communicating with the accessibility
service so something similar that people
like to do is manage accessibility focus
themselves and again this is a bad idea
accessibility focus is to be determined
by the accessibility service and just
like announcements this creates an
inconsistency in experience and actually
that's one of the biggest issues that
accessibility users face inconsistency
across applications and over time you
see there are a lot of applications and
if you as an app developer decide to
break with the paradigms of
accessibility interaction from the rest
of the system you're making your users
lies frustrating because now that
accessibility user every time they open
your application they've got to throw
out all of their expectations in terms
of how their interaction works and
they've got to relearn this whole new UI
at a very fundamental
so the best thing that you can do for
your accessibility user is the main
maintain consistency over time and with
a system okay now that you know how to
fix your issues she's going to talk
about how to find them and how to make
sure you fix them Thanks Cassidy hello
everyone so now that we know what we are
building for and how to build it the
next office question is how do I know
what I built is correct things like is
my text visible to most of the users or
is my button large enough or even if my
button is labeled or not wouldn't it be
nice if someone could check that for us
well there are several approaches in
which you can answer this question and
make the testing tasks easy on a high
level there are three approaches that
you can leverage as a developer to
ensure you are creating an accessible
experience for most of your users
the first is automated tests this
technique requires some coding changes
and is very good to detect accessibility
issues at the very early developmental
phases you can run these tests alongside
your existing UI unit or integration
tests as a part of pre submit or
continuous integration solution the next
tool we're going to look at is the
access pliny testing tools these tools
do not require any technical knowledge
and can be run by QA teams and release
managers to perform a sanity check
before your app is released out in
public and the third is a manual testing
which by experience we've realized is
one of the most effective ways to ensure
you're creating an end-to-end experience
for users with disabilities in
real-world scenarios let's take a deep
dive into the three techniques let's
first talk about integrating
accessibility into your existing testing
code most of the Android accessibility
testing tools are backed by the Android
access really testing framework it is a
Java library that is written on a
rule-based system to evaluate Android UI
constructs for access Brady issues at
runtime
remember it's open source so if you wish
to make contributions and add checks for
accessibility please reach out to us on
github so what does this framework test
for it tests for missing labels which
actually prevents users of screen
readers from understanding the content
within your app it looks for small touch
targets which can prevent users with
dexterity issues to interact with your
app it also looks for low contrast texts
and images which impacts the legibility
of your app and it looks for other
implementation specific issues which can
actually prevent your app from sending
the proper semantics to the Android
accessibility framework so that was
about the framework and we understood
what the framework tests for the
question is how do I use this framework
so if we've made it really easy to
integrate this accessibility testing
framework into the existing testing
frameworks like espresso and robolectric
these are provided as an optional
component and you can use an existing
test code to run these checks as you
interact with the view in your tests
these accessibility checks run
automatically before proceeding so if
you're interacting with a button in your
test we look for the button and
potentially the UI around the button to
look for access bloody issues for
espresso you can't use accessibility
check start enable to enable the tests
the result of accessibility choc
text or enable is an accessibility
validator which can be used to customize
your tests for example you can use dot
set run checks from root view to
increase the coverage of your tests by
running them onto the on the entire view
hierarchy wherever view actions is
performed you can also call dot set a
suppressing result matter to whitelist
known accessibility issues so that your
tests are green as you fix them it is
required that you use a view action from
the view actions class to perform these
tests in this example you see the use of
click action
remember if you interact with the view
directly you bypass the access bloody
checks for robolectric you use at
accessibility checks annotation to
enable the tests test will be enabled
when you
yes we'll be calling the view when you
call shadow view dot click on the view
you wanna test and much like espresso
you can customize your test using Robo
electrics accessibly utils so that was
all about automated test making changes
in your code and figuring out issues
accessibility issues are the very very
early development phases next we're
going to look about look at is using the
access bleedy testing tools these are
automated tools and do not require any
technical knowledge the first we're
going to talk about is the google play
pre-launch report it is an automated
tool that crawls your app on multiple
physical devices and looks for
accessibility issues so that you can fix
them before launching your app it looks
like for issues like crashes performance
and now even accessibility we've made it
really easy to get accessibility test
results by integrating those directly
into its developer console these checks
run on all apks released on any place to
attract pre-launch report is located
within the Google Play console beneath
release management you can see here is a
list of issues that are highlighted by
the pre-launch report these issues are
clustered characterized and ranked by
severity here is a detailed view of how
a report looks like generated by the
pre-launch report you can see the text
with the incorrect contrast ratio is
highlighted and a suggestion is provided
to improve it on the left hand side
panel you can see the occurrences of the
similar underlining issues being
highlighted for each of the
accessibility findings identified by the
report there is a learn more link which
gives you a detailed understanding of
the concept and provides suggestions to
improve it yeah that was about the
Google Play pre-launch report now we're
going to move on to the access pretty
scanner
it's a nagger app like scans our UI and
looks for potential accessibility issues
like missing labels or small touch
targets etc you do not require any code
change to use accessibility scanner all
you need to do is go to the Play Store
download the app or visit GGO slash
access pretty scanner launching the app
will take you through the setup process
here is an app that we've
created to highlight some of the known
access trade issues you can see a blue
floating button on the UI this is the
button that appears when you switch on
access 3d scanner in order to scan my
app I would simply tap on the blue
button while my apps UI is in the
foreground here is an example of how a
report created by access PD scanner
looks like you can see the text within
correct ratio is highlighted it's not
just highlighted but also a suggestion
to improve it as provided you can share
the reports by scanner via email or
Google Drive and if you click on the
learn more link it prove it opens a
detailed documentation of the concept
and the issue you're looking at so that
was about the automated tools we looked
at the automated test tests which
required coding changes and are good to
detect issues while you are developing
next we looked at the automated testing
tools which were the pre-launch report
and the access biggie scanner the third
technique we're going to look at is
manual testing so automation is really
helpful because it helps you detect
issues while you are developing but it's
not a complete solution as it comes with
certain limitations let's look at them
if you're depending on your automated
tests and they're based on the tests
that you've already written for your
code it's performance very much depends
on the coverage that your test test code
provides parts of your code that are not
tested can have serious accessibility
issues secondly like any other
automation there are always chances of
false positives and false negatives we
strive to reduce false positives as much
as we can but that can result in
neglecting some of the legitimate access
bleeding issues I'm totally there are
certain issues that require human
judgment and intervention for example
our tools can tell you that you're
missing a label but whether or not the
label string is making sense to the user
is understandable and acceptable is
something that only humans can decide so
manual testing is all about
understanding your users and
understanding how they're gonna interact
with your app using assistive technology
one way to achieve this is working
directly with these users or with
accessibility needs and so eliciting
their feedback it can be done
formally or informally another way to
achieve this is using androids own
access PD services so testing your app
with talkback can actually ensure that
you're providing the correct semantics
to the Android accessibility framework
and testing your app with switch access
can ensure that your app is reacting
well to the actions initiated by these
api's at Google we've learned that the
most successful teams are those who
adopt both automated and manual testing
in their development process if you want
to learn more about using google's and
androids accessibility services please
visit geo / Android accessibility and it
can also take you through step by step
approach to testing with keeping access
bleedy in mind and with that I will let
Phil come up and give some key takeaways
thank you thank you Isha hopefully you
found this information useful but as you
work on your app so really what we're
asking is for you to help us help others
use your app and help other
accessibility service developers help
others use your app so we've presented a
few api's here we hope you'll use them
to share UI with as many people as
possible one thing if you're played
around with accessibility before you may
be wondering like why are we not showing
you like we could have gone through the
details of like accessibility node info
and accessibility event and our goal is
really to try to limit the number of
people who ever need to crack that API
surface open this new API for adding
actions I think is really important in
that respect because it used to be if
you were doing something relatively
minor overriding the touch the touch
handler it was like okay you did the
small change and now you've got a crack
open this great big API surface and like
to figure out how to modify your
accessibility node info we have an
accessibility action API you needed to
add you needed to go through and
override a method in view and but a lot
of people like they kind of come up
against the learning curve like that
like you know I'm kind of okay with my
touch handler just kind of being
like that and I feel bad about not
having it be accessible but I just don't
have the time and so we're hoping that
these API is sort of reduce that energy
barrier to one line of code that's
pretty straightforward and so we hope
that you'll use them
similarly testing for accessibility
there's all different ways to do it we
all hope that you'll go out and do find
a wide range of users and test for
accessibility with all of those users
and I know some of you will but again
we're trying to scale this to the entire
ecosystem and so that's why we've got
these different points where if you want
to just do a quick scan we've got
accessibility scanner we've got
something even after you've uploaded to
the Play Store you can get a quick check
for accessibility but the more you do
the better the experience will be
overall and also as you go through and
you do this testing and you find weird
problems and then you start thinking
like I know
Cassatt said don't do this don't add
announcements don't try to control focus
but it's just broken like the only way
to make my app better is by just
tweaking it a little bit like you find
yourself sort of digging through maybe
the talkback source code which is online
to try to figure out what talkback is
doing and like okay how do I sort of
give it the right signals that it'll do
the right thing please realize that
you've probably found a bug and it's
probably our bug and we're eventually
going to fix that bug hopefully we'll
fix it a lot faster if you tell us about
it so if you find yourself doing
engineering and realize if you're doing
engineering for accessibility you're
doing a lot more than the average
developer and we need this ecosystem to
work for every developer in order for it
to work for every user so if you find
yourself doing engineering and you
realize no one else in the world is ever
going to do this as cos that said you
end up building something that's
inconsistent with the rest of the
platform even if it's better and so if
you found something like that please
tell us we're monitoring the AOSP issue
tracker we monitor Stack Overflow
reach out to us if you're stuck or
you're just doing something that's way
harder than it should be because that's
the only way
that's the best way we can get feedback
in prioritize our own work and really
scale the actually you can submit a OSP
uh um you also if you want to submit a
code patch to a OSP if you found a bug
in the framework I'd very much
appreciate that too um but if you can
have if we do the engineering it can
scale through the entire ecosystem and
so if you've got the extra cycles to do
that much to think about it that deeply
please do think about at the level of
like how could how could listening that
I figured out work for everyone and
figure out how to upstream it and reach
out to us so I started with three things
I'll finish with the three things just
making information visible prefer simple
big controls label images precisely and
concisely we're doing a previews and
office hours and it was striking at
yesterday as people were coming out
found that most of what we're saying is
essentially in these three categories
that really if everybody does these
three things we're gonna be a lot of the
way there it's a speaking of that we've
got accessibility office hours and app
reviews that are happening over back
that way we've got an accessibility
sandbox which is again just outside on
the other side here this on going
through all of i/o and so these are if
you've got questions to ask us will also
be outside you can come find us after
the talk and if you want to just explore
the world of accessibility we've got a
sandbox for you so with that thank you
so much for coming and thank you for
your interest in accessibility
[Music]